i'm really glad actually that she's
resigned i think it's about time she did
because um they need a much stronger
leader
in the metropolitan police
right you would have preferred would you
that she had resigned earlier
yes which um much earlier because um
week in week out there's
more and more things that are coming out
from the metropolitan police and i just
don't think that she was making any
difference
and why do you hold her responsible for
the investigation
into your son's death
not no not i don't hold her responsible
for the investigation but what i do hold
are responsible for is not policing the
police
which is her job to do she's supposed to
be in charge of them all
and they seem to literally get away with
whatever they want to do
and she refused to accept did she in
your view that that prejudice
played a part
in the
what was a botched in the investigation
into the deaths
yes when when i met her just before
christmas i actually said about the um
homophobia side of it and she totally
disagreed she told me how fantastic they
met where for
um gay
police officers and that they loved it
and she just wouldn't have any of it
and so was it her the way she dealt
afterwards with
your son's
murder or was it a a number of things
over the years put together
i think it was a number of things over
the years because um
when i met her she said about all these
policies that are coming in place and
things like that but
the thing is if originally they'd have
listened to me and listened to anthony's
friends
then the other three boys wouldn't have
died and it's no good apologizing now
and saying we're learning lessons it
costs three lives
and what were you saying
to them at the time
i was saying to them um
when anthony was found i said to him you
know was he shot was he stabbed was he
beaten up and it was nothing and all
they kept saying is it's not suspicious
i said well people don't just drop dead
in the street
and i kept saying to them
okay if you don't want to listen to me
listen to his friends something's not
right
and with it by within a fortnight that
shut the investigation down totally they
just wouldn't listen to anybody
and so i mean i'm interested in what
your thoughts were when this report into
the charing cross
police officers came out because that
was detailing
you know some years on misogyny but also
homophobia and racism and so forth
um i had a conversation with my mother
about this actually and she said to me
oh my god it's actually going back to
the 60s and 70s
how
the metropolitan police were then and
you think they'd have moved on by now
i just think it's appalling in any other
profession this wouldn't be allowed but
they just seem to be able to get away
with whatever they want to do
doesn't it show
that you know this is ingrained in the
in the culture of of the metropolitan
police
yes definitely and i think it's going to
take a long time to
sort this out because uh whoever comes
in has really got a job to do
so how will they sort it out i mean it
it suggests possibly that the problems
go a lot deeper than than
just the commissioner of the
metropolitan police
yeah i do think that um it has to start
at the top
definitely the
superintendent's chief inspectors and i
think have to have a lot more control
over the officers underneath them
because it showed in the inquest that
the failures went right to the top you
can't just say it was a particular
officer or rank of officer it was right
across the board
so
what would you like to see happen now
i would like somebody to come in
and
actually
do what they're supposed to do not be a
political puppet sort the bad apples out
because there is a lot of very very good
officers and they're all tarnished at
the moment with the
bad apples
and when you think back
you know over the years because you've
had a tremendous fight really on your
hands what goes through your minds when
you think your mind when you think about
you know what you've had to do to get
some sort of
uh justice really for this
i just think it's so scary the fact that
if i hadn't pursued this and the taylor
sisters hadn't he'd just carried on and
on and on because the police were no
never catching him
and that is the scary part of it that
the public are having to actually do
their jobs for them
okay well sarah sack thank you very much
for your time appreciate